i mean i don't think people should even
be thinking this that work here can we
get different questions like less
questions any questions i mean these we
feel are people's real questions okay
we've got a problem logan wants to see
you in his office
now
hey guys pete here this will be my
succession season 3 episode 3 breakdown
and i've got to say i think these might
be the best two back-to-back episodes in
the series so far you could make an
argument for last season's panic room
and turn haven and i think the two
season finales are the best episodes
overall but the one-two punch of mass in
time of war and the disruption this week
has the show reaching new levels and
you'd love to see it the kendall saga is
just the tip of the iceberg how
completely self-absorbed he is making me
hate him his move at the town hall
making me root for him shiv's
retaliation making me feel bad for him
and then still sort of managing a win at
the end after taking it all in i'm just
really happy in my headspace and i hope
they're happy in theirs real quick this
video will contain spoilers if you
aren't caught up through the third
episode of season three so this is your
chance to leave and with that out of the
way let's get into it
while this is arguably a kendall
centered episode after all he gave his
siblings a chance to choose sides and
they chose logan i think that shiv was
involved in the three most interesting
exchanges in relation to where things
are going she chose the role of
neutralizing kendall which led to a
one-on-one at a dinner for the committee
for the protection and welfare of
journalists of all places he leads with
a half-hearted apology which opens the
door for her to negotiate an outcome
that would minimize damage to the
company when she points out that they
both have the same aim and losing the
vote being bad for everyone at the
shareholder meeting he sniffs out what
she's doing and says he feels sorry for
her which puts them back where they were
at the end of last episode in response
she throws out or do you not actually
give a [ __ ] and it's all just ego and
this highlights how interesting
kendall's character is at this point of
course there's some truth to it all
being about ego but there's this other
layer that we saw in the game of good
tweet bad tweet and his insisting to try
to engage with this new character sophie
who's roasting him on her comedy news
show he's being earnest when he says
that she loves him he really believes
he's part of the conversation and on
some level why shouldn't he when he
yells [ __ ] the patriarchy unironically
he can overlook how cringeworthy that
might be because he thinks he's on the
right side of things morally he misses
how cynical that seems to everyone else
and thinks that being able to laugh at
himself and showing that he gets it
gives him a pass i love how that echoes
the corporate damage control line we get
it in a way kendall's trying to manage
the narrative around who he is as a
person in the same way that a
corporation does yeah of course it's bad
it's built in but hey we can say the
right things at the right time and
eventually everyone will move on to
something else what stands out about
this back and forth between kendall and
shiv is just how much the siblings all
hedge things around their personal
position at the base level they're all
trying to get approval from logan which
is more or less impossible and that
leads them to turn on each other at the
drop of a hat the last two episodes
really underline their inability to get
behind each other and how perfect that
is for logan as a way to manipulate them
i thought shiv trying to get conor and
roman to sign on to the letter was a
great example of this the decision
becomes a pure binary help shiv or
protect myself there's no debate no
discussion that she might be able to
change her approach or do things in a
different way there is real aversion to
how personal it is and how putting the
family business out there is wrong but
the decision seems to be more motivated
by a lack of upside for the two brothers
the next big moment involving shiv was
just after this when she goes to see
logan and tries to get an idea of how
bad this situation with cruises could
turn out to be when she points out that
the government has an unbelievable
amount of leverage at its disposal the
law he lays things out for her he says
the law is people and people is politics
and i can handle a people and again why
shouldn't he believe that everything in
life is transactional for him even his
marriage as we saw in this episode with
marsha returning or at least negotiating
the terms of doing that and so what
stands out in this conversation between
shiv and her father is what his strategy
will be the final pivotal conversation
for shiv is with tom he talked to his
friend and laid out in hypothetical
terms what he was involved with and
learned that it is likely he'll have to
go to jail if things get out the setup
here with tom being drunk and having
just had to help their dog mondale pass
some of shiv's pantyhose that he tried
to eat was perfect in that it gave him a
chance to deliver the line mondale's not
well mondale's unsettled before laying
out a pretty serious situation initially
shiv tries to dismiss the idea of him
offering himself up as a fall guy to
logan but then she reconsiders saying
that it would never come to that but
this could be a good idea because he
would bank some gold with dad in the
process he goes through with it and
logan echoes his daughter saying that it
would never come to that but he does
look impressed at tom coming forward and
offering himself up asking for nothing
in return which kind of shows that shiv
was right why this seems important
though is it makes tom a wild card he
definitely can't feel as confident as
they do that he won't go to jail because
he's the one that would actually have to
go to jail i don't think that this was a
setup or a test like he asked her to see
if she would protect him or stand up for
him or something like that but i do
think there's a limit in how far he'll
go to be a yes man in this situation he
does have that other side of him we see
come out when he deals with greg and the
people that work under him we saw him
put greg in a terrible office as
punishment for signing with kendall
earlier in the episode so at the very
least he'll try to pass the blame off
onto someone else and he certainly could
try to do something more dramatic he
also went straight to make a call which
is likely a number for a personal
attorney that his friend gave him the
night before which makes this story
really interesting going forward all of
that is to say that both kendall and
logan run into some major problems with
their plans ken realizes in one way or
another that people have a level of
accountability that corporations don't
have when shiv's letter goes public you
can see him start to realize this as
comfrey says no i wouldn't say it's
nothing and yeah but it's not private at
first he's more concerned about still
going on the show and it doesn't really
hit him until he realizes the show won't
get on board with not bringing it up and
we see this all play out in this great
sequence with him walking down the hall
and finding a quiet place to hide jeremy
strong kills it here doing the whole
range from manically on top of things to
broken and cowed in a minute and a half
and as i mentioned in the opening you
can't help but feel for him a little bit
here on the other side of things logan
has a meeting with michelle ann the
white house aide that jerry got on the
phone in episode 1 when they couldn't
get the president after a heated
exchange she leaves things at if his
news channel were more favorable to the
administration the president would have
a better reason to go to bat for logan
unfortunately for him the deputy ag
finds out about the meeting and because
logan already refused to cooperate with
a subpoena earlier in the episode they
decide to move on waystar's offices with
a search warrant in hand with cameras
outside recording all those fbi agents
arriving there's really nothing they can
do after being assured by jerry that
these are the people that don't [ __ ] off
logan's left with no choice but to
cooperate which probably isn't a good
situation for him and we see that
reflected in kendall's face when he gets
the news
and that's where things are left it's
all out war at this point i don't think
there's another way you could describe
it there's still the shareholder meeting
coming up but the fbi's involvement
definitely takes things to a different
level and there were a lot of great
little moments thrown in there along the
way greg who's always been
self-conscious of his wrists but a forty
thousand dollar watch that he thought
was broke because he didn't realize he
had to wind it not sure what his new
lawyer would think about that which is
another thing that's going on that we
didn't really touch on in this episode
we did get to see jerry acting in her
role as ceo although there was real
concern from logan that she might be a
puppet trying to come to life and the
one decision she made and told carl to
follow through on he completely
undermined the nate sighting was a
particular interest considering how
things have been heading with tom and
shiv i don't know about you but i fully
want to see the picture of conor with a
ponytail and the sequence where the
security guard colin came into kevin's
office and leaned in telling him i know
you was pretty heavy considering that he
was the one that was involved in the
cover-up of kendall's manslaughter back
in the finale of season one the nazi guy
who was being protested last season
still has the show on the network and
that's why the white house aide was
there to be on that and it's called the
bunker okay
also the fact that logan called the
president the reason to his aid really
makes me want to know what's going on
there this definitely seems like
something he's going to rely on later if
the feds start to get close to him
personally i mean part of the premise of
this show is that a guy like logan roy
is somewhat above the law right also i
saw a lot of people saying they thought
tom was behind the donuts and that he
might have been the one that tipped off
the fbi honestly i don't think either
one of those makes sense but tom may be
in a different place next week after the
raid went down and i did love his
handling of the announcement at the
dinner party for the advertisers that
they were being raided all of the
corporate damage control stuff was a joy
to watch in that it all did a pretty
good job of showing that no one involved
cares about the very real crimes that
were committed it's all spin and that
did make kendall's use of nirvana's rape
me hit home really effective track
selection there it sets up the crushing
letter from shiv later and you know you
can kind of understand where each of
them were coming from both of these felt
like escalation beyond the normal
squabbling between the family members
and we're only three episodes in so
there's room for this to get pretty
insane we still don't really know much
on the legal side of things from kendall
besides that he hit up his high-powered
lawyer to see if they could get a raid
which went over about as well as his
ill-advised meeting with the writers on
the tv show she did mention that they
were negotiating a queen for a day
situation where he'd have immunity which
that could be huge but honestly it's
hard to imagine him being able to find a
way to sink logan without taking the
company down at the same time the last
thing before i wrap this up was roman
having to co-opt his one happy childhood
memory of connor taking him on a fishing
trip to say that it was actually his dad
only to have logan [ __ ] on him in return
it makes you wonder how much of that
roman would be able to weather it was
incredibly harsh and you had to feel for
him a little bit there but it's still
kind of unthinkable that he would go
against his dad but i mean at the same
time everyone has a breaking point right
if you look at that along with shiv
probably upping her position by going
after kendall in true killer fashion
jerry sort of being relegated to a
puppet status you see that there's less
room for roman to feel great about his
position after this episode so it will
be fun to see how that develops and each
time i start taking notes for one of
these episodes i start jotting down all
these memorable quips only to reach the
point where i realize it's basically all
of them they pack so many into each
episode that it's impossible to mention
them all so i think this is a good place
to leave things but do let me know in
the comments what your favorite lines
from the episode were let me know what
you thought and where you think things
are heading please like this video if
you enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon